どんな 152ページのかんまむらっていうところ
そこら辺はすごく簡単で
かんなむらっていうのは
業というね カルマは なぜ行為はカルマになるかという
その原因のことですね
そこでテイスパナティパトパリサワーチャービャーパードーチャドーサムーレーナジャヤンティ
パナティパティ 殺生すること
パリサワーチャって何でしたっけ
まあ粗悪語 それから品位
ビャーパでその 3つの業は
この 殺害 心根によって生まれるんだと
殺生することも それから人に悪口を言って叱ったりすることも
それからこの心意ということも怒りに基づいているんだと
その中でだいたい殺生することは体
一応主に体でやる行動で
よく疑問になっているのは
この殺生は全部怒りですかという問題は
たまたま人々は聞いても
そこで仏教 いろいろなテキストで考えてみるんですね
例えば美味しい魚が見たら
あまりにも美味しいんだから
それを取って食べると
あるいはもう楽しくて釣りをやっているでしょうし
そういうのはみんな楽しくやっているものだから
で 殺生するし 狩りにね
行ったりするしね もうイギリス人というのは
まあ前はね まあキツネを狩り狩りに遊びに行っても食べる事もしないし
ただ追っかけて行って殺して帰るんです
何匹殺したんですか？って言って
また自慢するんですね
で まあそういう風に遊びにしているんですね
それでアジアやアフリカからそこら辺にその人々が行ったところでも
もう片っ端からみるみる動物を殺してしまっちゃうんですね
で スリランカあれ世界でどこにもいなかった
ある特別な種類のゾウがいたんです
すごい小さい で 今から考えたらすごく珍しいものなんですけども
で まあ小さくたってもゾウですからね
それなりの大きさありましたけど
今はである あの国の山の上である小さな地方でしか生活できなかったんです
それはもう 100  200年前でもう全部片っ端から殺しちゃったんです
で 遊びに簡単に殺せるということで
ゾウは殺したぞと で まあそういうふうにこの
で まあまあ 今は私たちによく説教していますけどね
自然を守りなさいとかね
まあとにかくそういうふうに
この動物をね まあ殺したりすると
もう怒りで 例えば蚊が体に止まって血を吸っちゃうと痛いし
もう嫌なんですね その時はもう本当に怒って
もうパチンと蚊を殺しちゃうんですね
怒りであることがすごくわかりやすいんですね
で それからこの怖いと殺すでしょ？で
山に入ったところで熊が襲ってきたんだと
それ殺されると熊に殺されると怖いし
ですから なんとかもってもうその熊を殺しちまっちゃうと
その場合 怖さ 恐怖感 恐怖感は怒りに入るんですね
仏教では なぜならば 嫌な対象が怒りと言ってるんだから
恐怖 くまみて殺されるという現象は好きなものじゃないんですね
ですから怒りなんですね
食べるために殺す場合はどうでしょうかとかね
特に日本でもこの牛とかね
まあ勝手は育てるし すごい愛情があって
なんか息子のように育てるんですね
で まあいくらかまあ 2
3歳になったところで
まあまあ売ってしまっちゃうんですね
肉のために で そこでまあ
とにかくもう それはあまり仏教では疑問にしてないんですね
この楽しみに動物殺すことも結局怒りですよと
なぜかというと その釣られる魚についてすごい可愛いですよと
幸福で楽しく生きていてほしいとかね
他の魚たちと一緒にいっぱい餌を食べて元気でいてほしいという気持ちがあるならば釣られますかと
釣られませんね その場合は
ですから 全く愛情はないんですね
で 逆に じゃあ食べるために鶏を殺す場合は
まあ食べたいという欲があるんじゃないかと
まあ慈しみはないのは分かりますけど
これは美味しいんだと
というと欲でしょう 欲で殺生できませんかと
で その欲があるのは鶏のチキンに対してなんですね
ローストチキンに対して欲があるんだけど
生の鶏に対しては欲がないんです
だから美味しいですよと思った瞬間に頭にあるのはもうローストチキンのことであって
生きている鶏のことじゃないんです
そこでローストチキンを作るためには
こいつは邪魔なんです
そんな風に遊び回って餌を食べていてはいけません
だから殺すんです ですから
まあ食べるためにチキンを殺した鶏を殺しても
そこに怒りが働いているんだということで仏教では決めているんです
そういうわけで すべての殺生は怒りに基づいているということになるんです
いつでも私は説明することになる
この瞋恚という こちらで書いているのはパーリ語でヴェーパーダなんですね
このヴェーパーダというのは心の業なんですね
3番目の で心の問題 心でずっと怒りをもう成長しちゃうというかね
卵を温めることで何と言いますか
卵とか温めたりするでしょう
あの ふ化 ふ化すること
そういうふうにこの我々の心の中で怒りをね
孵化するんですね どんどんどんどんそれを膨張して強調していっちゃうんですね
それにはこのあまり根拠はあってもなくても構いません
なんか性格みたいなもので
怒りを育てる人はずっと心の中で怒りを育てたりするし
だから随分この原因もなく恐怖感があるんだという人々はよくね
いるでしょう すごい恐怖感でたまらないとかね
不安でたまらないとかね
そういうの全部怒りなんですね
で 心の中で怒りを育てるんです
で そこはもう精神的に言えば
まあちょっと異常であって
病気なんですね そういうわけで
私はこれ異常な怒りといつでも訳するんです
ヴェーパーダは ただの怒りというふうなことではなくて
なぜかというと人はよく怒るんです
別にそれは普通なことで
何かあったらすぐ怒った
またそれも忘れたと で
そういうふうなことで
怒りも怒りも欲ももうもう繰り返して回転して怒るんです
この場合はそうじゃなくて
怒りが心に生まれたら
それはもう止まってしまって
どんどんどんどん孵化して
もう膨張していっちゃう
その人は人に殴ったりけなしたりとかね
悪口を そういうことをしない
ですから体で行動はしない
言葉でも行為をしない
ただ内面的で 嫌な気持ちを育てる
怒りを育てる 恐怖感を育てる
不安な気持ちを育てたりはします
で そこでこの一般の社会から見れば
あまり問題にはしないんですね
社会には問題ないんです
例えば もう言いたい放題悪口言う人がいるならば
これは社会問題なんです
それはその場合はその人がとんでもない人だと
社会に迷惑だと思って戒めようとする
それである人が暴力振るったりすると
その人はさらに悪いんだと思ったりはするんです
でもそれは社会についての問題であって
心の場合はそれはそれほど関係ないみたいですね
ですから このあまり怒りなくても
ほんのわずかな怒りで人を殴ったりすることもできるし
それほど怒らなくても
言葉が上手な人にとってはいくらでも悪口を並んでしゃべることもできるし
で もう一番あの重い罪というのが
仏教ではこの瞋恚なんですね
ヴィーパータなんですね
ですから もう社会ではあまり大変な大きな罪だと思わなくても
仏教の業の立場から見れば
やっぱり大変罪の重さがちょっと硬いというかね
重いんです 重さが多いんです
じゃあ悪口言う場合はどうですかと
悪口言う場合は まあどうせ心の中怒ってるんだから悪口言いますけど
悪口自体はそんなに問題にはしない
それは悪いことは悪いんだけど
まあ順番で言えば心の中で根拠もないのにも
この怒りを付加することは大変な悪いことだと
で 原因もないしね 例えば人にいじめられていじめられたんだから人が怒ったというならば
それはそれほど精神的な問題じゃないんです
いじめられたんだから怒ったんであって
いじめられなかったならばその人は怒りません
でも 心の中 怒り成長する人は
やっぱりいじめられてもいじめられてなくても怒るんですね
で それはまあですから気をつけなくちゃいけない大変重い罪として見ているんですね
輪廻転生する場合も 心は自分で回転するんだから
怒りの方向へ回転する心はどうせ慣れている方向へ回転するんだから
強烈な怒りに回転して不幸になってしまうんです
そういうわけで このもう遊びででも心の中で怒りの感情
怒りの妄想は作ってはいけない
そこが危ないんです ちょっとでも癖になってしまっちゃったら
どこまでそれやるかとはもうコントロールできないんですね
妄想の流れっていうのは
生まれたらもうすごい勢いで回転しちゃう
ですから 楽しみみたい
楽しみとしてでも 冗談ででも
やっぱり心の中でも誰も知らないんだからということででも心の中で怒りの概念をするってはいけないということになっているんです
じゃあ次の語は セーサーニチャッターニピヴィーヒムーレーヒサンバワンティ
何も書いてないんだ で
他の罪というものは 怒りか欲かどっちかで生まれることはできますと
他の罪っていうのは あの泥棒のアダプターですね
盗むこと 怒りでも盗めるし
欲でも盗まれるんですね
ですから 盗む罪はどっちかになるんです
それもそれは場合は分かりやすいんですね
まあ怒ったところで 人に何か損をしてあげようと思ったら
その人に何かを盗むことは可能であるし
何かを欲しくて欲しくて盗むことも可能ですから
この盗む病気があるんですね
あれは何でしょうかね
なかなかわからないんだけど
で それは病気として見られるのは
このまあ例えば日本みたいにものに溢れているし
別に不自由っていうことは何もないし
盗みそうは全くないんですね
それなのに盗んでしまっちゃうし
それをすごい快感でなかなか止まらないし
じゃあ盗んだものは役に立つかって
その人に役にも立たない
別にどうってことない
何かを盗むだけなんですね
[笑い]やっぱりその場合もどちらか怒りか欲かどっちかでしょうね
まあ例えばすごいあの捕まった
例えばサラリーマンとかね
もう会社で立派な仕事をしている社会人たちも
こういう万引きとかやってるんです
何を盗むかというと もうあのカップ酒とかね
缶ビールとかね で 平気でポケットに入れてもう行っちゃう
出て行っちゃうんですね
だから本人も知ってるし
これ言われたら仕事も終わりし大変
ものすごい恥ずかしいし
もう大変なことなんですね
で 何のためにやるかと
で まあもしかするとそういう人々はそのすごい危険であることを怖いと
命は終わりと それ見つかったらというすごいその怒りを怒りの刺激を味わっていると思いますね
ですから まあ一旦ちゃんと店から出て見つからなかったらまあセーフだと
と言って またその同じ恐怖感を味わいたくなっちゃうんです
そうすると それはやっぱり精神的な病気になってしまうし
まあ癖になるし 大体は怒りみたいんですね
そういう精神的な病気になる人々っていうのは
ほとんどの場合は怒りなんですね
欲で精神的に病気になる場合は
もうそんなに可愛いんですね
何か美味しくて病気になったとかね
で 落ち込んでしまったとかね
振られたんだと落ち込んでしまったとかね
そういうのはまあそんなに治り難いとこでもないんですけどね
まあ他の人から見てもなんとなく可愛く見えちゃうしね
振られたんですかと で
それでまあもうそのうちなんとかなるでしょうとかね
親切になんとかね まあ助けてあげることはできますけど
怒りの場合はなかなか助けてあげることもできないしね
人の話も聞かないし ですから
この現代社会では見られる精神的な病気のほとんどは
まあ怒り 失望感とか怒りから生まれてくるものだと思っても構いませんと思いますけど
まあそれからこのカーメスミッチャ
不慈悲はどうでしょうかって
これ不慈悲も入りますけど
不慈悲はどうやって怒りでできるかなとは問題なんですけどね
そっち書いてますかね
そういうことは  じゃあ今日はローバムぐらいになってます
トントンになってますけど
ミッチャサット カーメスミッチャサット
どこ？ カーメスミッチャサットはヴィッチャ
ヴィッチャヴィッティチャット
ローバクズレ  だからこっちがだったらこのテキストで何書いてるんですかね
どこにありますか  百五十三ページ
ああ カーメス ミッチャーチャーアビジャミッチャディッティってロバマウレー
それ抜けちゃったね 私は
で 不慈悲とあの阿比陀っていうのはまた何の欲ですか？じゃい
貪欲 で また邪見というのはまあ頓根心だと
で まあ不慈悲は欲であるということはまあ分かりますし
このアビッジャっていうのは
またあの怒りと同じく
この限りない欲であって
根拠なく心の中で欲を育てるんですね
で それも大変な病気なんですね
欲しくて欲しくて いろんなものはたまらなくなると
別にものを欲しくて それ得ようとすることじゃなくて
頭の中でいっぱい妄想だけしてるんですね
ああなればいいんだ こうなればいいんだとかね
あるいは自分がまあこういうこういうものだ
ああいうものだとかね
で その欲が限りない欲
心の中である人々を見ても
本当にすごい病気だなとわかるぐらい
もう変なんですね 普通じゃないんです
で 心は自己回転するんだから
いくらでも欲を作ることはできるんです
まあそういうことで まあ精神的な病気 2つですね
まあ怒りと欲は まあ他の
ミッチャーディッティはまあちょっとわかりませんだけどね
ミッチャーディッティはもう頓根にしているんですね
邪見も その まあ何かにしなくちゃいけないんだからそうしてると思いますけど
で 一応よく考えて考えてしてると思います
で この邪見でどのようにできているかというと
結局怒りか欲 どちらかなんですね
で 生きていきたいという存在欲がある人々はね
まあどうせ誤論的な考え方を作ってしまっちゃうし
で 実体があるんだと 神様がいるんだとかね
天国があるんだとかね
で であんまりこの世の中に
さて失望とかね あったりする人々は
まあ破壊的な破壊的な
ね 邪見持ってる人々は結局怒りなんですけどね
そういうのは何の意味もないんだとかね
道徳なんか何の意味もないんだとかね
もう天国なんかあるわけないんだとかね
で だから私から見れば
かなりのきつい怒りで哲学を作る人々は結構いるんです
だからそれどっちにも両方に入れた方がいいんじゃないかなと思いますけどね
なんでこれ頓根心に入れてるかというと
このインドの唯物論者という論者のことを考えてるんですね
インドの唯物論者っていうのは
まあ何と言いますか 贅沢すぎなんですね
どうせ人は死んじゃったら
もう土は土に行くんだと
水は水に行くんだと だから生きるとは
生きている間はもう楽しめばそれは得だよと
で 死ぬまでですからということ
人生はね だから明るく楽しく
まあもう生きていきましょうと
もう人生は短いし ですから
すごいこの何て言いますかね
あれ 何論と言うんですかね
一つあるでしょう このヨーロッパでも
この食べて楽しんでいるすぎ
うん 快楽なんです 快楽
快楽主義 快楽主義は正真正銘の頓根っていうのはわかりますね
インドにいた当時のこのこの紀元 6世紀の唯物論者様も結構快楽主義でした
ですから マークス主義とだかね
そういう風にこの破壊的にはいかなかったんですね
で まあ唯物論が後で随分後でね
ヨーロッパでできたんだけどね
そのユダヤ人の間ではね
それとはもう 怒りで作ったものなんです
強力な怒りに基づいて作ったんだだからそういう国々でももう人殺したり
もうすごいものが現れちゃうし
そのものも破壊してしまって
教え自体もそれはもう怒りに基づいているんだから
怒りっていうのは破壊することだからね
だから育てるということはないんです
そういうわけで 共産主義的な政治システムというのは
なかなか育てるということはまずない
なんとか維持はしていますけど
怒りに基づいて ですから
あの来た掃除したって口調したっても
帰ってくるニュース見ると
とにかく怒りだけ育てて育てて
もうなんとか維持しているんですね
ですから 成長というものはね
ないんですから そこでやがてもう倒れますね
まあ怒りですから で インドの共産主義の人々は別ね
政治活動とかそんなもう面倒くさいと
時間ないんだと その時間でもよくみんなでみんなで仲良くご飯食べて
歌でも歌って踊ったらどうですかと
ということになっちゃうんですね
だからこの誰にも目をかけなかったんです
だから人は死んでからもうそれで終わりだから
泥棒しちゃってもいいんじゃないかと
それは言わない 泥棒しちゃったらもう結局苦しいだけやと
だから見つかったらまた大変苦しいし
もったいないんだ そんなことは
で 有名なその人々のお経文句がありまして
リナンクルトアダディンティベという言葉ありまして
借金してでもあのダディっていうのは
なんでしょうかね おそらくヨーグルトだろうと思いますけど
ヨーグルトとあれ牛乳で作る油がありますね
あのインドでギーと言うんですけどね
英語で まあすごい臭いんですけど
臭いって言ったってミルクの匂いは強烈なんですね
で バターとは違うんです
バターは塩つけて固まっていますけど
あれはもう固めてもない
一応半分固めて半分固めてない状態でね
で コレステロールかなり強力だと思いますけどね
あれすごい好きなんですね
インドでは だから油量が少ないんだから
料理なんかに使っちゃうと
もう大変な贅沢であって
それから料理何にも油かけて
それはそのまま食べたりする
その油はとにかくこの牛乳で作っちゃうんですね
牛乳を沸騰したら上膜が出ますから
その膜を集めた集めてもうちょっと沸騰すると油が出ます
で あれは腐れません 薬には使います
とにかく で その人々というのは
まあだからすごい贅沢だからね
もう借金でもしてそれ買って食べろと
で 借金どうやって払うかっていうことあまり気にしない
そればっかり食べちゃったら早く死ぬかもしれませんしね
借金払わない で ですから
そこらのその人々の影響を受けて
怒り 邪見はすべて貪瞋痴だと
こういうアビダンマテキストなんかで言ってるだろうと思います
私個人の意見では 怒りに基づいても邪見作られるし
欲に基づいても邪見を作られる
それでどうしてもアビダンマの方
今日のテキストの方を正当化したいと思うならば
たった一つの糸口があるんです
人が自分で邪見作ったらすっごい気に入るんですね
自分の思想だから それにはものすごい執着するんです
財産よりも命よりも 人間というのは自分の考え方や思想には執着する
殺されても考え方だけは変わりませんと
独立シチアン主義ですね
もう殺されても隠れてでもやると
というふうに 何か意見が心に入ったら
もうなかなか捨てがたい
すごい執着なんですね
それは邪見には大体限るんです
正しい意見というのは
人間というのはすぐ変えちゃうんです
そういう弱さもあるんです
で まあですから この執着するが故に邪見は貪瞋痴だよというならば
まあそれはそうかもしれません
自分の意見嫌だったらその自分の意見じゃないんです
不可能です こんな考え方嫌ですよと思う人がそんな考え方持たないでしょうに
ですから 自分が考え方を持っているということは
その考え方を自分が好きということなんです
例えば人を差別したりするね
まあ考え方世の中であるでしょうし
神様にあるグループの人々だけ作られたんだと
すごいかわいがってるんだ
あるある民衆だけはね
そういうふうなことを言っちゃうと
僕の腹が立つんですね
なんであの連中だけかわいがってもらってるんですかと
ですから 誰に怒るんですか？だから神はいないと
これ考え方 自分だけ偉くて他の人を差別することで言ってるんだから
それは嫌だからね だから間違ってでもその意見は私の好みにはならないんですね
ですから 自分の邪見にはならないんです
というのは その考え方自体はもともとからも嫌ですから
もし考え方 あ これは結構立派な考え方だなと思っちゃったら
自分の邪見に意見になる可能性はあるんです
だから気に入らなきゃ自分の意見にならないんですね
だからそういうわけで
もう邪見は貪瞋痴になると
私はどっちでも言いますから
どっち？どっちが取ればいいかわからないんです
自分でも ですから まあ別二つの立場あります
怒りに基づいて邪見は作られますが
それは自分の意見だから
それには執着する まあ大体そんなところでやめます
それは難しいことじゃないんだから
それで 盗むことやらもぐやら
離観業と起業ですかね
そういうのは怒りでも欲でもできるんだと
次にあの善 あの善行為のことに入ります
あの二十二の で カーマーチャラクスラアンピカーヤドワーラーマーチャラクスラカッマというところ
カーマーチャラクスラカッマアンピカーヤドワーリーパワッタンカーヤカッマワチードワーリーパワッタンワチーカッママノドワーリーパワッタンマノカッマンチェーティカマドワーラワセーナティーリダンホーティ
善行為の場合も体中心にやるものは身門ですか
身門に生じる身業 で 言葉中心にやるものはまあ何語？まあ語語かな
で それで意識で考える行為は意業と
いわゆる心身の行為のことですね
えっと こっちはtathaダンナシーラバハバナーヴァセーナチットウッパダヴァセーナパナエタンアッタウィダンホーティ 48
種類になりますかね わかりますかね
このどうやって8種類になるかと
あ？欲界？でしょう だから欲界
先心症のこと 心のこと言ってるんですかね
うん 全然その言葉ではわからないんです
チットウッパダ・ヴァセーナと
欲界 あの欲界善行為といえば
心は8種類あるんですね
よくマハクスリチッパという風に
ソーマナッサハガタン
ニャーナサンパユッタん
アサンカーリカチッタン
ササンカーリカチッタンとかね
ソーマナッサハガタン
ニャーナサンパユッタん
アサンカーリカチッタン
ササンカーリカチッタン
それで4つと ウペッカーサハガタ
ニャーナサンパユッタん
アサンカーリカチッタン
ササンカーリカチッタン
ウペッカーサハガタ ニャーナサンパユッタん
アサンカーリカチッタン
ササンカーリカチッタン
それは8種類なんです
どこかにありましたと言いますけど
テキストの中に そういうのはあまり簡単単純にも
まあパーリ語で言うならばさっさと言えますけど
別に問題なく 2 3分で全部
で 一応今言った8種類のね
まあ心があります あの
いいことをすると 普通の人がいいことをすると
あのどんな心が生まれるかというと
この8種類の中で一つ
例えば喜びがあって 智慧があって
まあ有業か無業かね そこで2つなんですね
それから喜びがあって
智慧がなくて 非智相応で有業か無業かと
それで4つあるんです
そこで捨 喜びはなくて
捨の感覚で智慧がある心は有業と無業 2
つと 捨の感覚で智慧がない心は有業と無業と2つと
そういう風な8に分けてます
その中で意味があるところは智慧があるかないか
智があるかないかということだけ
このあの喜 喜相応と言うんですか
喜相応か捨相応というのは全然結果では利がないんです
結果として それから有業無業っていうのは
唯識信の場合はまるっきり無関係なんですから
もうどうでもいいことだと思いますけど
で 一応人がいいことをすると二つの差が明確なんですね
一つはちゃんと知恵が働いている場合と
もう一つは知恵が働いていない場合と
知恵が働いている場合っていうのをよく理解して
これはいいことだと そういうのはやらなくちゃいけないんだと
当たり前だと いいことをするのは
そんなものは当たり前だというぐらい気持ちでやる人々はもう智相応と言うんですね
知恵があると そういうことを考え
ああそうですか じゃあやりましょうとかね
面倒くさいんだけど まあみんなやってるんだからしょうがないとかね
あんまりそういうことに意味も関心なく
いいことをする場合は知恵がない状態ですね
で これは本格的なアビダルマに入っちゃうと複雑難しいんですけど
まあもうこれここら辺
まあ軽々く終わりにしたいと思ってますから
で この一応業のことだから
我々日常生活に大変必要なものだからね
少々ちょっと続けて説明しますけど
だから当たり前だと思っていいことをすると
いいことをするのは当たり前だって
それはもういいことはするべきですよという理解があると
もう知恵があるんですね
そこで人がこういうふうに考えると
いいことをすればいい結果になるんだと
いいことをすれば世の中はちゃんと認めるんだと
そういう気持ちでいいことをすると
例えば まあ布施をすれば
もうもう一億倍になって戻ってくるんだと
決してもう布施するお金なくなるわけじゃないんだと
生まれ変わるたびにもう恵まれて生まれるんだからやるぞと思ってやる場合は
どうで それ知恵があるんですかと
その人は本当に業のことも考えている
倫理のこと考えている
いいことをしたらいい結果が出るんだと
いいことをする人は 世界ではちゃんとちゃんと褒められるんだと
認められるんだと 悪いことをする人は認められませんと
そういうわけで私はいいことをしているんだというと
智相応ですか？非相応ですか
その場合は痴不相応なんですね
あれは商売やってるんです
だから汚れてるんです
布施をするんだけど もう巨大な結果をもう計画立ててるんですね
得られるんだと ですから
まあその場合はやっぱりいいカルマはいいカルマなんです
善行為は善行為なんですけど
痴不相応になるんです
ですから 結果が弱い だから痴相応の行為するのはなかなか人間に難しいんです
痴相応の行為すれば それは三因になっちゃうでしょ
三因の業になっちゃうんで
三因の業になってどこかに三因で生まれ変わったらすごい巨大な人なんですね
例えば瞑想でも簡単に成功するのは三因
成熟身で生まれた人々なんです
そういうわけで少ないんです
だから三因の善行為をしたければ
智相応の善行為をしなくちゃいけない
で その人 それすごく難しいんですね
心のシステムをね 何か結果がなければ
やっぱりやりたくなくない
やりたくはないんですね
人っていうのは もう最低褒めてくれるぐらいでもなければね
だから人の布施する いわゆるね
何金ですか 寄付金とか何とか集めるのはいとも簡単なんです
何とか名前で何とかの何とかとか何とか資金とか作ったりして
もう例えば五 六人の名前
嘘でもいいんだからね
お金払ってテレビでコマーシャル出すとかね
そういう資金にこういうこういう人々がこれぐらい寄付をしましたとかね
で すぐにそれに寄付をする方々はこちらの番号に入金してくださいと
ただそれだけ それでお金入るし入る入る場合にもう報告と新聞報告かテレビで報告出しちゃえば
新聞出すならばね テレビで何時間にこの時間でこの日は報告しますよと
コマーシャルで流れますよと言ったら
二 三週間で何億も集まると思います
何のこともなく それぐらいもう簡単なことなんです
で そこでどういう働きかというと
やっぱり心のこのカラクリなんですね
で まあそこら辺をこんなにアビダルマ勉強していてないんだけど
人々はいくらかはわかってるんです
ですから このいろんなところでね
金集める噂ね もう大変身についているのは
確実にその人々の名誉欲